three two one booster's indignation
and liftoff of Artemis one we rise
together this was the Third Time Lucky
for NASA's Artemis project after
technical problems and hurricanes
stopped two previous launch attempts of
the Orion spacecraft
it's a test flight if it succeeds then
in a couple of years there'll be a crude
flight around the Moon followed by a
lunar Landing of astronauts
we also need to test the Technologies to
send humans into deep space and and to
the moon and then beyond to Mars so
there's really Uh there's Big scientific
reasons to go back to the Moon there's
big technological reasons to go back to
the moon this is the most powerful
rocket NASA has ever built and it
signals a change in direction for the
U.S space agency's human space flight
program after the six Apollo missions
from 1969 to 72. since then NASA has
focused on low earth orbit with space
shuttles and the International Space
Station it's the beginning of a next era
it's the beginning of building on all
the lessons of Apollo and taking them
even farther bringing the lessons that
we learn on this Mission both back to
Earth and also applying to even deeper
space exploration going on to Mars
answering some of Humanity's most
fundamental questions there
the Orion capsule will be on a 25-day
flight before one of its biggest tests
the durability of its heat shield which
needs to withstand re-entry friction
temperatures of
2760 degrees Celsius
ultimately NASA wants to establish a
base on the moon as a stepping stone to
even more ambitious human voyages to
Mars
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera